people have a lot of different visions
of what the future is going to be with
autonomous vehicles and it kind of
divides into two worlds one group has a
very utopian view a v's will deliver all
of these social and environmental
benefits but there's also a dystopian
view I'm David Malakoff I'm a deputy
news editor here at science and I edited
our autonomous vehicles package our two
reporters who looked at the phenomenon
of autonomous vehicles realized that
there are a lot of obstacles in the way
to the full deployment of fully
autonomous vehicles so it turns out when
you survey people they actually have a
lot of apprehension about getting into a
navy and so there's actually a lot of
research now going on looking at how do
people perceive a v's not just the
people who are inside them but also the
people who are outside them around them
so for example when a Navy pulls up to a
crosswalk how will a pedestrian know
that the car has seen them right and
recognize them how will the car
communicate with the pedestrian what
it's about to you but also inside the
car so for example researchers are
experimenting with things like cars that
talk to the passenger vitor detected
updating route in order to reassure them
and tell them what the car is about to
do or video screens that show the
passenger what the car is seeing all the
landmarks the pedestrians the other cars
so one of the interesting debates among
people who study autonomous vehicles is
how safe to the cars actually have to
get before consumers will be persuaded
to use them and that they're worth
putting out on the road in terms of
saving lives
so on one side are people who say boy
you know consumers are never gonna
really trust these cars until they are
perfectly safe which is a little odd
right because right now we accept a
pretty high level of risk when we get
into our cars right people are unwilling
to get into a navy that might be just as
safe as current cars that are on the
road because you know they have a sense
that they don't have control
there's another group of scholars who
have a slightly different view they say
look we should get some minimum
increment in the increase in safety say
3% or 5% or 10% and just start putting
those cars on the road get them learning
how to become better and then over time
you'll get safer and safer cars so
ownership is an interesting question a
lot of companies they're building babies
are imagining a future where they are
selling to fleets
so imagine uber or lyft or taxicab
companies where the entire fleet our
automated vehicles in the dystopian view
there's also an equity concern which is
that some people will have access to
this technology and other people well so
for example people living in cities
which have well built infrastructure
might have easy access to a v's but
people who live in rural areas where the
infrastructure is not so good might not
have such easy access a lot of the big
unknowns is how are people gonna
actually use these cars it turns out
there's surprisingly little research on
this but there are some studies going on
one was quite clever to mimic behavior
of using a Navy our researcher agreed to
give a number of families in California
access to a chauffeur-driven car for a
week that would show up whenever they
wanted and do whatever they wanted it to
do and then she compared the use of the
chauffeur driven car to how they drove
the week before they had the chauffeur
driven car and the week after they had
the chauffeur drone cards what she found
was they actually took many more trips
traveled many more miles
so that feeds into this idea that a v's
may not necessarily reduce car use they
could increase car use I think the
bottom line of our two stories is that
amidst all this hype surrounding
autonomous vehicles people need to step
back take a deep breath and realize
things may not happen quite as quickly
as they seem and that they should really
be a little skeptical about all of the
claims that are being made about a v's
maybe the hype has outrun the reality
and eventually there's going to be a
balancing out
you